driver moszer is accused of
live-streaming hundreds of rides without
telling his passengers the driver worked
for the uber and lyft ride-sharing
services near st. Louis he streamed the
rides through a live video website
called twitch the st. Louis
post-dispatch reports some riders were
told that cameras were there just for
security vladimir duthiers our streaming
network that cbsn shows us the backlash
jason Garg accra ported lea filmed
hundreds of rides with passengers
without their knowledge and streamed the
footage online for a live audience for
the sake of privacy had not shown you
guys anymore I'll probably forget half
the time Garg axed which channel had
more than 4,500 followers and has earned
more than 3500 dollars since March the
things that were in those videos were
very embarrassing st. Louis
post-dispatch reporter Erin Heffernan
said several riders didn't know they
were in the videos until she told them
there was children elderly people and a
lot of you know intoxicated people that
were out drinking in the you know the
bar crowd both uber and lyft say they've
deactivated Garg acts accounts uber said
in a statement that the troubling
behavior in the videos is not in line
with our Community Guidelines lyft
spokesperson said the safety and comfort
of the lyft community is our top
priority
Gaga tweeted on Saturday that some
people suggested getting rid of the
videos he saved online he wrote I've
done that for now Gaga didn't return our
request for comment for CBS this morning
vladimir duthiers twitch told us quote
we do not allow people to share content
that invades others privacy